[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: More
and more enterprises
are modernizing
their infrastructure
by moving to the cloud
and adopting DevOps
as a way to deliver
better software faster
and more reliably.
Thanks to our friends on the
DevOps Research and Assessment
Team, we know that, on
average, the best performing
organizations see a higher
deployment frequency,
have less lead time for changes,
have a lower change failure
rate, and take less
time to restore services
after a failure.
A big part of excelling
at these four key metrics
is having a robust and
effective continuous delivery
pipeline in place.
If your software
development team
is developing and delivering
container-based applications
on GKE, that can be
challenging, especially when
you've got dozens or even
hundreds of pipelines
across multiple environments.
Introducing Google Cloud Deploy,
a streamlined, fully-managed,
continuous delivery
solution for GKE.
Google Cloud Deploy addresses
these challenges in three ways.
It's fully managed and scalable,
it has built-in security
controls, and it integrates with
your existing DevOps ecosystem.
Since it's a
fully-managed service,
that means there's no expensive
infrastructure to setup
or maintain for your GKE
continuous delivery pipeline.
Whether you're a small
startup or a large enterprise,
Google Cloud Deploy scales your
continuous delivery process
seamlessly and manages
it via simple declarative
configuration.
And however your
operation scales,
you can have a centralized
view of all of your pipelines,
releases, and deployments
across all of your Google Cloud
projects.
Google Cloud Deploy was designed
with safety and security
in mind.
By leveraging IAM
for easily defined
and granular access
controls, you'll
be able to designate the
right people to manage release
promotions, and roll out
and roll back changes
to each environment
with a few quick clicks.
And Google Cloud Deploy
provides audit logs right out
of the box, enabling you to meet
your regulatory and compliance
goals as you scale
your release velocity.
Google Cloud Deploy is designed
to work with your existing
DevOps ecosystem of products.
Google Cloud Deploy
functionality
is accessible via
CLI or API, and is
able to integrate with
popular tools you already
love, like Cloud
Build and Jenkins
for continuous integration.
Google Cloud Deploy also brings
scaffold to your pipelines,
improving the
reliability of pipelines
by insulating them from
changes to your tool chain
and application architecture.
Sound good?
You can learn more about Google
Cloud Deploy by checking out
cloud.google.com/deploy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]